today we're gonna be doing a comparison
that so many of you guys commented and
asked about we're comparing the
brand-new 2020 13-inch MacBook Pro with
a new tenth generation Intel processors
against the 16 inch MacBook Pro and
finding out which one you should spend
your hard-earned money on how much of a
performance difference do we have going
up to the 16 inch or can you get away
with just getting this 13 it's just much
more compact smaller and also lighter
we're not only going to be comparing the
performance of the CPU and the graphics
we're also going to be talking about the
keyboards the design the displays the
webcams speakers and much more let's
start out with the physical differences
and what these guys opened up you guys
could see that even though on paper 16
inch doesn't seem like that much bigger
than 13.3 in reality it is a massive
difference the screen is much larger the
whole body is much larger and if you
guys could tell the bezels are slimmer
on the 16 inch Apple put in a larger
display whereas the 13.3 inch is the
same Apple did not upgrade to a 14 inch
and recently there's been even more
leaks and rumors about the 14 inch not
coming probably for at least another
year so if you guys are waiting on that
that's probably gonna be a long wait now
let's go ahead and close these guys up
I'm gonna stack the 13 inch on top of
the 16 inch here just you guys to give
you guys a size difference it is pretty
substantial and if you're used to the 13
inch this thing seems massive along with
that we have weight differences 13
inches just over three pounds compared
to this is 4.3 but it does feel a lot
heavier in the hand with that said it's
pretty surprising that the thickness is
almost identical and one really great
thing about this higher-end 13-inch is
that it also has four Thunderbolt three
ports just like the 16 inch so you're
not limited in connectivity opening
these back up the 16 inch was the first
MacBook to get apples magic keyboard
this has more key travel it is more
reliable uses scissor switches much
better than the butterfly keyboard Apple
now brought that to the 13-inch MacBook
Pros it's identical keyboard the touch
bar is now separated from the Escape key
so that is excellent the keyboards are
identical the track pads are also
identical they're excellent as far as
the technology
and how they work the 16-inch one is
larger and it is absolutely massive but
it is excellent and it does a good job
with rejecting palms and anything like
that
the last physical difference is the
speaker grilles the 16 inch MacBook Pros
much larger so as larger speaker grilles
and Apple definitely packs some great
speakers in here we'll do a comparison
here in just a bit but first let's talk
about the displays both of these screens
are excellent they're all nice and
bright 500 nits with good anti
reflectivity coatings and they both have
a high a high pixel density the 13-inch
has just over 4 million pixels whereas a
16 inch has 5.9 million pixels but
because the screen is larger it about
evens out one thing that I do have to
mention is that if you're a professional
you're doing photo editing especially
video editing graphics design it
definitely is nicer to have this larger
screen you have more space for tools for
settings not that you can't do it on the
13-inch but you do notice a difference
and it is more comfortable as long as
you can handle the larger size both of
these displays have excellent color
accuracy and they both are capable of
displaying dcpip three colors which is
about 25 percent more than your standard
srgb if you guys see this little box
here you see the logo on the inside most
laptops cannot display this shade so if
you're professional you're working with
colors both are going to be great and
now it's time for our speaker comparison
you guys get your best pair of
headphones Apple made a huge deal about
the 16 inch MacBook Pros featuring six
speakers being their best system for
sound the 15 inch isn't bad either so
let's go ahead and compare them and I
want to let you know that you guys asked
for a different song we finally found
one let's go ahead
I want to say that was surprising
because we just compared the 13-inch to
the base model which has worse speakers
and to the XPS which has aware speakers
and it sounded fantastic but now putting
it up against a 16 inch it sounds bad
and it actually doesn't sound bad it
sounds great
but the 16 inches sounds amazing
basically like you have better base you
have crisper highs but the mids stand
out so much I only noticed one decibel
difference on my Apple watch as far as
volume but the sound quality difference
is huge both of these MacBooks feature
720p webcams so this is the quality of
the video and audio you can get from the
13-inch MacBook Pro and this is the
webcam and microphone quality from the
16 inch MacBook Pro and Apple calls the
microphones in this MacBook Pro Studio
quality so you guys let me know what
differences you notice down in the
comment section below and now it's time
to talk about performance and I know you
guys are all waiting for this the
13-inch is very interesting because we
finally have better CPU and much better
graphics performance so some people are
wanting to downsize from a larger laptop
and we're going to find out how much the
performance difference is there we're
gonna start out with Geekbench v i'm
gonna go ahead and run it another very
interesting thing is that this year for
this model Apple has given us 16 gigs of
RAM bass you don't have to spend extra
money for that that's great they've
never done that before we also have 512
gigs of SSD just like the 16 inch we
have tension processors whereas the 16
inch this one has 910 which are
basically the same as 8th gen this is a
6 core so this is going to get
interesting and we have our results and
they are interesting as far as single
core the 13-inch MacBook Pro is about
15% faster now single core is used for
some very simple tasks and even for some
video editing like generating waveforms
that's usually single task that is being
used now as far as multi-core our 16
inch with a 6 core processor gets close
to 30% higher performance which might
make a difference in the photo editing a
video editing which we'll test in just a
bit and I just mentioned that both of
these have 500
12 gig SSDs so let's go ahead and do a
Blackmagic speed test see if we see any
differences so right away as far as
right it is a little bit higher and as
read even Marshall let it go one more
time here so it looks like we have about
a hundred megabytes per second faster on
there right with the 16 inch about 600
megabytes per second faster with read
speeds so there is a difference even
though the SSDs are the same size but
with most tasks you're not going to
notice a difference and now let's touch
on the graphics I'm gonna run Geekbench
fives metal test this is probably one of
the biggest differences between these
laptops the 13-inch MacBook Pro has
integrated graphics built into the CPU
and even though it's a big improvement
compared to last year the 16 inch has a
dedicated graphics card and here we have
the scores we have practically 10,000
for the 13-inch and basically 25,000
for the 16 inch that is a massive
difference even though we have much
better much more power for graphics with
the new 2020 compared to 2019 13 inch 16
inch still is way ahead let's take a
look at gaming
this is Unigine heaven it's a gaming
benchmark and right off the bat the 16
inch looks really smooth we're getting
38 40 frames per second compared to
about 13 for this scene that is a big
difference alright we're about done here
both the fans did spin up but the 16
inch is noticeably louder but do keep in
mind we're getting a much better
performance and that dedicated graphics
chip is using a lot more wattage so here
you guys see the difference we have 13
and a half fps compared to 45
it's a massive difference in terms of
gaming if you're somebody that wants to
play games if you can handle the larger
size you're definitely gonna have a much
better experience with the 16 inch and
now it's time to test Cinebench our 20
which is gonna give us another look at
the thermal performance and fan noise
and what these CPUs are capable of when
they're put under a 100 percent load say
you're rendering you're transcoding
doing those kind of tasks so right off
the bat we see 91 watts that the MacBook
Pro is you
using that's a lot of power for the
16-inch this will run up to 40 watts so
the 13-inch one has a lower wattage CPU
and that is going to make a difference
in ultimate performance and the 16 inch
even though we have six cores it's right
now hitting 3.6 gigahertz compared to
3.0 with the four core the 13-inch went
up to hunt degrees Celsius fairly
quickly whereas the sixteen inch it is
getting hotter now but it's a much more
gradual curb and what this means is if
you're gonna put a quick 20 second
intensive blow it on the system the 16
inch is gonna stay silent where the
13-inch is gonna kick up its fans a
little bit earlier the 16 inch just
finished up and right when I was
finishing up the fans ramped up and go
almost as loud as the 13 inch but it
finished the task and the 13 inch looks
like the fans are maxed out now and the
13 inch is now a done we've got a
thousand six hundred eighty 4s by the
lowest score that I've seen one thing
that I think maybe if you're plugging it
into power
I noticed unplugged it actually got that
highest score so that is interesting
maybe also with fans there's a
difference whereas the 16 inch got 2700
so basically another thousand points in
CPU performance now that we know these
performance differences in terms of
benchmarks let's see how they actually
apply in the real world we're gonna
start out with photo editing using
Lightroom
I have 50 42 megapixel RAW images opened
up here and those are no joke when we're
just switching through with these
photographs you see there's a little bit
of a delay that's because I already have
a bunch of effects stacked on these Raw
clips the 16 inch is slightly faster but
not by that much the 16 inch is super
smooth no issues whatsoever but the 13
inch also does a surprisingly good job
I'm seeing very little delay now let's
go ahead and export these 50 images and
see the difference we get so it's been a
minute and there's already some very
interesting things happening both these
computers are using a hundred percent of
their CPUs but the MacBook Pro hit a
hundred ReCell seus very quickly the
fans are spinning up getting loud 16
inches silent and it's at 84 degrees
Celsius so was at 81 it's slowly
starting to heat up but there's a big
thermal and noise difference when we're
doing this now as far as performance
they're not that far off surprisingly
now it's been two minutes
the MacBook Pro 13 inches fans are at
full blast whereas a 16 inch is
completely silent at 2700 rpms
all right so we have our results and I
want to say first there are three things
that surprised me first
the MacBook Pro 16 inch is much much
quieter second the GPUs were barely used
so even though we have a much more
powerful graphics card it's really not
doing much for photo editing and third
is the speed the 16 inch took three
minutes and 11 seconds and the 13 inch
took three minutes and 28 seconds that
is barely any difference it's really
insignificant I was expecting this to
take about 50 percent longer now the
team and I were talking about why do we
have such a little difference even
though the CPUs are maxed out all the
way and I think we found their reason
and that is their RAM speed difference
both are using ddr4 Ram but this is
using twenty six hundred megahertz Ram
compared to three thousand seven hundred
so 40% faster Ram and in the past we
noticed that for photo editing Ram
matters much more than a lot of other
things so having this faster ram is
making up for the difference in CP
performance that is crazy so if you're a
photo editor and you want to get a
smaller laptop this 13-inch is going to
do an excellent job you're not missing
out on much and if you're professional
we would suggest going for 32 gigs of
RAM we have notice that it makes a
difference having more RAM as well for
photo editing and it will actually get
faster it's great we have that option
now and now let's talk about video
editing I have Final Cut Pro opened up
here this is a simple project but I do
have filled green applied I also have to
Lutz applied which are kind of like
filters but it's a little bit more
elaborate what it's doing to the colors
and if I go ahead and play this back
both these laptops actually handle it
fairly well and the fact that Apple
switched over to the ten nanometer chips
with the better graphics really helps
out on the 13-inch MacBook Pro as doing
way better than it did before and the 16
obviously is not gonna have any issues
with this I'm gonna go ahead and ex
or this and I'll see what kind of a time
difference we get so we're about two
minutes into the render and I notice
something very interesting the 13-inch
MacBook Pro it's only using about 20% of
its for core processor compared to the
16 inch which is using almost 50% of its
6 cores and that is because the graphics
card is limiting the 13-inch even though
we have the better graphics card now
it's still not enough to keep up with
everything or this thing the graphics
card is maxed out and the CPU is at 50%
another interesting thing is that the
fans are spinning up quite loud now on
the 16 inch because you're pushing so
much power to the graphics card the CPU
where the 13-inch unlike photo-editing
it is silent right now that's
interesting so obviously the graphics
are holding it back but if you're
interested in seeing a video like this
maybe a performance video but adding an
external graphics card unit a GPU to the
13-inch let us know down in the comments
section make sure you guys have
notifications enabled alright and that
took three minutes and 36 seconds on the
16 inch for a 5 minute project 4k with
all these effects so it's faster than
real time whereas the 13-inch was only
at 33% done so far and I actually did
this rendering test earlier and took 9
minutes and 58 seconds so obviously that
is a pretty big difference a 16 is just
three times as fast in video editing if
you have a couple effects compared to
just slightly faster in photo editing
now the 13-inch is still very capable it
still does a good job especially in
final cuts and if you want to see what
kind of video editing you can handle
I'll leave a link down in the video
description below to my filmmaking
channel and I have a video up right now
about this machine and how it can edit
and I'm also going to be doing a more in
depth to video editing comparison
between the 16 and the 13 so if you guys
want to see that video make sure you
guys are subscribed to the link in the
video description and now let's talk
about battery life now Apple rates the
16 inch MacBook Pro at 11 hours of use
compared to 10 hours for the 13-inch but
that is just for video playback with the
screens being fairly dim if you're doing
you know mixed use in the real world the
13-inch MacBook Pro will get 7 to 8
hours of battery life and the 16 inch
show will get 6 to 7 hours a little bit
worse and that is because it has a lot
more powerful hardware the CPU will use
more watched a lot of spikes spikes
higher and the dedicated graphics card
even though it does switch back and
forth between integrated when it's using
that dedicated it uses a lot more
wattage now if you're going to be doing
something like photo editing or maybe
even worse video editing on battery
power the 16 inch will get around 3.5
hours of video editing compared to about
5 hours of video editing for the 13-inch
because it has a lot less power that it
is drawing now of course these do use
USB type-c for charging so we would
highly suggest buying a USB type-c power
bank that can output a high wattage and
that way you can not only not lose any
of your battery power when you're on the
go you can actually charge up the
battery at the same time while doing
some of these tasks we're gonna leave a
link in the video description to an
excellent one that we highly recommend
and now let's talk about prices and our
final verdict on which one you should
buy for your specific use task so
originally the price difference was $600
but it got a lot more difficult more
complex the previous MacBook Pro it only
came at 256 gigs of storage and eight
gigs of RAM so once you add up to 16
gigs and 512 there was only a $200 price
difference and it made it even more
difficult a few months after the 16 inch
came out when these were discounted
which you can actually get him right now
for about 200 dollars off we'll leave
some links in the video description and
the price was the same and that you're
choosing between much better performance
or the smaller form factor now Apple
made 16 gigs standard 512 standard and
the price difference is even bigger than
before and which kind of makes it tough
now if you're somebody that is doing
photo editing and you like the more
compact size this is a killer deal right
now now if you're somebody that does
graphics design you do say video editing
especially for your game
we would highly recommend if you can
deal with the larger size and a little
bit heavier weight go for the 16 inch
we're seeing a massive difference in
exporting 4k video in gaming performance
the graphics card really helps out not
wait and for 200 bucks off right now
you're getting a really good value as
well as for those of you guys who are
doing encoding or you're doing a music
production and those types of tasks
I think the 13-inch is also an excellent
value the cpu performance is better the
single core performance is better
graphics performance is better and now
for the first time ever you can actually
get 32 gigs of RAM on a 13-inch and that
definitely matters for some of those
tasks to be able to run multiple
applications some people are doing
virtual machines and previously you had
to go up to a 15 or a 16 inch in order
to get 32 gigs of RAM you don't have to
do that anymore so the 13-inch is
actually much more capable now than
before it fits a lot more different use
cases and it's an excellent machine let
us know your guys's thoughts down in the
comment section below and click that
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe and all as well you can enable
those notifications if you want to see a
couple other great videos we have some
right over there this has been max with
max tech and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]